hey guys my name is Jess I'm here with
Callie and we are very excited to be
interviewing you guys from Ben Studios
John and Jeff thank you so much for
joining us
as I said to you when I saw you first
you guys have one of the biggest games
of the show days gone is huge I mean
we've seen it for two years running now
and how excited are you to be brings out
some what soon I'll do we were so
excited we've been working so hard on
this game I know we haven't said a lot
in the last year but the whole team has
been sort of gnu's down yeah just really
doing our best and to make the best game
we can how long you been working on it
now for four plus years well plus years
Wow Wow all right so where did where did
it come from what did it birth from that
you wanted to make days gone kind of a
mishmash of things really but I mean
John John had a vision for for kind of
the apocalypse and a lot of the ideas
came from just looking out our windows
at the office you know and so you know
that kind of inspired the environment
and all of the situations came from what
would I do if I were stuck in this
parking lot down here when yakult's
happened what would I do to survive what
I do to get home and just kind of that
kind of grounded our premise and a
reality that we've got maintained the
kind of I think makes it relatable for
people and I think kind of something
that they've unbelievable even though
yeah okay yeah I want to do an
open-world yes because that's you know
because we're all gamers we love those
games and then we were trying to think
okay what can we do that other games
haven't done so then we hit on the idea
of having a motorcycle as like a primary
way of getting around and not having to
be disposable but having it be something
that you really care about it oh yeah
okay well who would really care about
their motorcycle we're all fans of Sons
of Anarchy absolutely no just the kind
of the idea is all decided core sort of
seemed to come together where you've got
like a guy who's tough enough is you
know can use his fists yeah rides a bike
yeah any guy that would survive and a
post-apocalyptic world so I want to ask
about this apocalypse because I think
I'm a big zombie fan I really like a
zombie fiction um what are these zombies
like cousin the trailer we saw there's
lots of hordes and I'm curious like
what's the origin of what happened to
the world so we call them freaker's
mm-hmm and the reason is because they're
still alive so it's a virus mm-hmm and
there was a pandemic two years ago so we
call it the event we don't really talk
about that yet there's going to be a lot
more information
about that coming up okay but yeah it
affects not just human beings which we
introduced this year but last year you
saw the Horde which is hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of swarmers and
when they band together like that they
all kind of move like one they think
like one yeah one they're made up of
individual swarmers which are adult
males and females and then we have newts
that we showed last year which are
adolescents or kids yeah and this year
we're due seeing the rager bear which is
an infected bear the runners which are
infected wolves Wow I don't know the
media shook eased um and saw them
chasing after DK now had they caught up
to him had he had heading out shot them
it would have knocked him off his bike
right that's just one of the dangers in
the world so that's what we try to do
with all the freaker's is make them as
dangerous as we can yeah and they come
for you yeah and we have the most
dangerous creature of all man yeah gonna
wait for the player yeah we saw a lot of
combat versus other humans like you know
aren't infected right I'm curious how
combat versus like a horde will work
well you talk a little bit more about
that about you you saw it last year you
know um in general it's just wrong I
mean yeah it's just not come on it's
possible but you have to you have to get
distance you get separation yeah a lot
of ammo you have to have a lot of
stamina you have to be just you have to
be at the top of your game yeah almost a
fully built character in order to barely
survive that but will have as well so
these these smaller swarms in the world
which are definitely more manageable but
I mean if you get overwhelmed by one you
get overtaken by all yeah pretty much
game over at that point and one of
things this is a term that Jeff came up
with it's called weaponizing them so one
of the things we showed off on our demo
is it's not just you run from them you
can use them against other enemies yeah
he has their own faction great and the
great news about swarmers is they don't
want to just eat Deacon they want to eat
everybody yep so that you know so you
can use them against Marauders yeah
that's cool when you like send them into
that that camp when your yeah into that
demo yeah that's cool I mean I think
this is a good point I really like to
talk about deacon because he's a really
interesting character we get we get I
don't know whether I would go to what's
calling him an antihero yet I don't know
if we know that but uh you get a lot of
heroes you get a lot of a you know
valiant people going out into the
apocalypse saving the world finding a
cure deacons not really that guy what
can you tell us about him uh yeah so I
totally agree
and what I try to do what you know
because when I write stories or when I
write period I really wanted to be about
change and to me you got to have like
you start with a character whose broken
in some way and like you saw in the
trailer last year Deacon suffered a
great loss but everybody has so what
makes Deacon different than everyone
else so that's kind of one of the things
we're going to explore during the course
of the game is like the question we
always ask ourselves is number one what
would you do if you were in this world
and you had to do whatever it took to
survive or to save your family or
friends what would you be willing to do
and so we explore that and as far as
just deacon it's like yeah I just think
he has a super interesting background
and that gives him a lot of texture and
you know so the answers are obvious like
yeah what would Deacon do does he have
an overarching goal is he just a dude
trying to survive I mean how does that
play into the overall story of the game
he does have an overarching goal and
again we're not talking a lot about the
details of the story all right but but I
can just tell you there is a huge story
and it's all about deacons journey and
you get a hint of that at the start when
Copeland who's the leader of one of the
encampments so these encampments are
were the law-abiding survivors band
together for protection and they've been
hit so you know Copeland who's the
leader that can go as a deacon he's hey
we got to get some men we got to go out
get these Marauders and things like not
my problem Yeah right and if that were
the whole story he'd be like wow what a
douchebag
I would actually need something which is
he's the bike mechanic yeah exactly
even though he rescues man he you know
he says that's me and it is his friend
but he tries to kind of play that off a
little bit like you know hey I'm I'm not
he really here to try to rescue I just
need you so yeah always this kind of
interplay between motives which I like
so is it fair to say we can expect him
to evolve as the game goes on I hope so
I would I would you just be one of those
games where your character just stays
the same person the entire time I know
I'm saying that that's cool I'd love to
talk about you guys as a studio this is
the first time you've been back in the
home console market for ten oh boy 15
years 2007 yeah when we had the Omega
strain yeah what's that like it's pretty
cool yeah nobody expected this out of
the studio the small you know we're
still well exactly I mean you've come in
swinging I mean you got a lot of Syphon
Filter fans you got a lot of I've got a
my coworker back there Dan
a huge fan of Syme villas areas um he
will be very happy that I've relayed
this but yeah I mean now you come out
swinging absolutely
well you know here's the funny thing
yeah if you played uncharted golden
Abyss it was a full console game it just
was on Abita so that is as powerful as a
ps3 old so it's simple you know so we
had so you know Chris Reece the studio
director technical directors I mean all
these guys were building next gen
technology and we'd been working on it
since you know 2010 so you know even
though it was on the Vita it was still a
con full console game yeah and one of
the things about our studio that I've
always taken pride in is a employee
there is that we were a lot of hats we
work really hard like who comes there as
passionate and is not content just doing
one thing for four plus years you know
they really want to get in to help in as
many ways possible and I think that's
what allows us to make something so much
bigger than kind of the sum of its parts
yeah and uh you know related sort of
question what is it like to be back on
your own IP I mean obviously guys have
been hard at work you know working with
your own creative ideas with other bits
and pieces in the meantime but now
you're out with something completely
brand-new yeah that's that's honestly
the best part of this is yeah you know
we're sort of the masters of our own
destiny now yeah and it's just it's
amazing to be able to create something
that you've you know from the early
stages it was very very rough we had a
lot of ideas yeah having the time and
that's the other great thing about Sony
is that they give us the time and the
resources to do right so yeah you know
so we're not in a rush to get this thing
we want to make it we want to make it an
awesome IP that will be very well for
the record I loved working on all those
other Sony franchise that's what it is
because we made those aims our own you
know we definitely did yes I'm we're
liberating to kind of have our own thing
to play with but you know it was it was
it was a lot of fun I take great pride
in what we did with yeah with resistance
and with uncharted yeah I guess bouncing
off of the console questions what about
ps4 Pro for days gonna know there's
going to be some enhancements can you
talk a little bit more about what we can
expect there yeah the biggest thing is
if you've seen the demo that we did last
year its HDR which you know it's
supported on ps4 as well as ps4 Pro and
then the 4k resolution so we're dynamic
4k and if you haven't seen it so we're
running our alternate demo right now on
the floor you get a chance swing by and
look at it in 4k on a 4k monitor because
it's amazing yeah what's the details
just stunning yeah what's it like to
balance like something so getting the
beautiful world but also a very harsh
world and even like in the highest of
definition cuz it's like it's hard to
appreciate the beauty of something so
grim so brutal yeah yeah so that was
kind of the whole idea was we we chose
the high desert not just because our
studio is there yeah right which it is
in the middle of Central it must be nice
but it's because of the because it is so
beautiful and so the thing about the
high desert is it's also in the real
world it's very extreme and very brutal
it can it can be sunny in the five
minutes later it can be snowing we've
seen it's snow in July and the whole
place is scarred by volcanoes so the
Cascade Range the mountains that you see
those are all dormant volcanoes are not
bad you know they're just dormant like
Mount Saint Helens erupted in 1980 that
could that could happen again right so
all the valleys the lava tube caves the
river basins everything is sort of
shaped by this and it's all very compact
and it's beautiful and so we thought
okay what better way to show off the
brutality of the action in our world
except against a backdrop that is just
amazingly beautiful yeah wonderful well
I hate to ask you a bunch of questions
you probably can't answer but uh you
have tased a very interesting wildlife
selection in the game and we got a
little taste of it with the zombie bear
is it safe to say it was that what we
saw a freak Robair freak a bit we're
actually calling it a rager okay oh all
right huh can you go into any more
detail about the beasties we're gonna
run into we can list off the ones that
we've shown so we have the runners which
are the wolves and those like I said
those will chase you down they will
knock you off your bike you can run into
them they're part of our open world
dynamic system so that all these animals
that you do run into you never know when
you're to expect them and that's I think
the biggest thing about the animals in
our game it like the human enemies like
the ambushes is it it's all about
bringing the danger to use yeah you
could be on a job or a mission buying
your own business just trying to get
somewhere and then boom suddenly you've
got runners chasing after you so it you
know that's that's kind of the way we
approach the development of them is like
what kind what do they offer in the
world in terms of making it seem alive
but also making it seem dangerous yeah
the runners are my favorite
kind of typical of my favorite part of
the game which is the player is going to
be doing one thing ya gonna forget about
thus far the world cuz it doesn't happen
all the time but when he least expects
it yeah boom there's something like the
runner because we saw a successful
outcome of the runner encounter if the
player would have failed and it wasn't a
clothesline there right the runner would
have effectively done the same thing and
knocked him off his bike and then it
would've been a showdown
you know tumbles off his bike and he's
face to face with this with this
infected wolf yeah it's a 1 was gonna
live one of them's gonna die yeah that
is the game it's just really exciting
how those moments can kind of punctuate
this silence the builds over time and
just really keep the players on their
heels
yeah really exciting I'd love to talk
about how much of a threat are the
zombies in this game because I feel like
every freaking how every one of the
zombie games not yours yours or Franklin
comes out it has it has a different kind
of level it's a different sort of threat
it's a different kind of danger for
every single one of these games I mean
you said it's difficult to face a horde
does it depend how well equipped you are
can you get to a point we can face off a
horde yeah absolutely there's an in-game
scenario where you you pretty much have
to and now the player has to kind of
build for that along the way you know I
mean every creature is dangerous in with
it so we got artists rank-and-file the
normal swarmers I mean they're fast
they're not shamblers they don't just
kind of like this and there's a lot of
them so you know if if the player get
surrounded even by three of them it
could be game over real quick if he's
not leveled up enough have enough health
if he doesn't have enough stamina to get
away yeah so it's something where the
player has to manage his resources and
it manages approach to everything just
constantly be mindful and it increase a
lot of tension I think for the player to
you know even when things aren't
actively happening in his mind they are
because it could happen when it happens
it goes bad absolutely speaking of how
dynamic are the zombies like popping up
and coming around me and obviously the
demo we saw at e3 this year it appears
like you know it's quite convenient
there was that whole horde around at the
time that we could unleash is that a
scripted event or um do they just appear
and disappear change and the world has a
set of rules to which is an ecosystem
thing that behave the way we would
expect them to behave kind of like the
watering holes where some creatures some
animals and nature go to drink and
others go to eat there's just there are
patterns and routines that develop that
you can learn to recognize another and
things that are places are more
dangerous than others and given our time
of day system in our weather system the
park and
factor into the the movement in the
appearance of creatures and humans
across the world
alrighty yeah and the thing to keep in
mind is that swarm outside the Marauder
camp wasn't there just by chance there's
this huge garbage pile there and so
there are things that you see in the
world like their mass graves yep there's
these huge garbage piles there's places
where you know there's wrecked vehicles
any place there's food that's where you
will find swarmers so the player can
begin to recognize these places and
again they'll come out certain times a
day and you know so the Marauders that
obviously built up that huge fence to
keep the swarmers away from them as long
as they have their own food source they
don't want to come into the camp yeah
it's also why they hang what we call the
meat walls so they'll I'll hang up dead
freaker's oh I was yeah that's a stop
there they don't come into the camp
right or they will they will take a
singer a single dead Freaker and they'll
put a bear trap under it because that is
if it attracts another Freaker snap
they've got another one or they'll chain
them to live ones two trees exactly okay
so act is kind of like an alarm can you
yourself do that too can you set traps
oh absolutely
mm-hmm so you so I could if I wanted to
hang up a Freaker and use it as bait you
can set snare traps yes Oh excellent
interesting well you did mention earlier
about the bike so you can't do keep the
bike with you the whole game there other
vehicles you're gonna owe the player has
one bike he's a he's a biker part of his
identity is wrapped up in that bike
before the apocalypse and afterwards and
mostly in this case just because it's a
machine that he's custom-made oh yeah I
wouldn't want to bet my bike either it's
got a lot of supplies that he carries on
it helped him to help them kind of
persist out in the field and it's
something where people in cars died all
over our broken road you see we seek
pileups where you know cars tried to
turn when they hit a road jam and they
just they all died whereas people on a
bike could just cut through could split
a lane or go through cars and just go
off road and escape and survive so it's
vital it's super important you don't
whistle for a new one you can't just
lose it in the lake and then and then
kind of go find another one and have to
watch it at all times no we're Evan I
love that you could have to hike across
a large swath of the world if you don't
if you don't
Wow that's fantastic probably and it's
exciting yeah people thought I was going
to suck at first but it's the one of the
coolest feelings where you like I should
have taken care of this I should take
this that same thing with the the fuel
yeah yeah I was gonna ask you about you
don't keep it filled up if you don't
know we're gonna scrap or materials
repair it it could break down on you and
yeah
stuck in and like I talk about the
watering hole earlier one of the cool
things about a world is that when you
need gas there's a few places in the
world where gas and that's where some
animals go to eat some human animals go
to get their next meal or the next the
next booty so is the world filled with
like caches and things like that or do
you really need to know the places where
you might find specific resources to be
able to get them there yeah you've got
to read the train you know the game is
built around if you think that you're
gonna need some gas you start to think
about well what if I look inside garages
or lawnmowers if I look at you know the
back at gas stations where would fuel be
and then you go to the other and it'll
pay off more often than not same thing
with food and other resources of player
needs if he needs I'm making this up but
salt he's going to go look in the
kitchen or somewhere and he's going to
morph or not it's going to be there so
that's what we want the players to think
we don't want to make anything up we
want to just kind of play into the
context of the world and let the players
use that as their guide yeah so do you
say this the survival elements are
really resource management based then
it's like it sounds like the bike is its
own kind of resource management and then
you have additionally you know finding
tools and finding supplies right yeah we
think of it as survival light because
first and foremost we're an action game
it's actually you know so you have you
have tool you have all these tools you
have you have weapons you have an
arsenal weapons yeah things you can
craft and you know we we wanted to sort
of balance the things like you know fuel
management for your bike we don't want
it to be so frustrating that that's what
the game becomes enough to drink water
Lee no right yeah we're not dead yet
yeah manage your temperature you become
a very different game oh yeah you just
don't want to do the stuff that this
feels more like work yep
right that's fit you want chores right
yeah yeah point well you did bring it up
briefly uh what's the weapon system
looking like right now what kinds of
things can we get our hands on how broad
is it well you like I said earlier we're
trying to keep the game believable and
and hyper related so they're things that
could realistically be found in this
environment before the apocalypse and
you know part of our earlier scenario
when we talked about what would I do if
I was out here in the apakah so Don them
to a man we're thinking well I'd go to
the the weapons store and I kill
everybody there and take all the weapons
yeah yeah yeah yeah and things like that
and so that's what happened in this
world is you know there's people who
have hoarded things people have all
these resources and the flour has to
kind of work to earn them for the ones
and the ones that he's finding in the
field aren't great you know they
kind of get them by they can be they'll
do for a while but they're not going to
allow them to really kind of build up
and take on a horde yeah those weapons
so he has to work to get a hold of the
better weapons other people have taken
and modified and kind of customized for
the apocalypse right I'm suppose they're
crafting then can you upgrade your oh
yeah yeah you saw some crafting in our
in our alternate path demo yeah a lot of
things have to do it yourself in tality
the MacGyver mentality just where you
know it's things that we find in here
and you know if we had to find something
to you know barricaded or you know
wouldn't look pretty but we'd find
something to do it with and yeah I've
had to build a weapon out of those
tripods over there we build some pretty
gnarly looking weapons we get it done
not do anything that crazy but it's
something worth it's all pretty
believable things that the player can
kind of find it and convert yeah and
just get by by the skin of his teeth
excellent well I mean personally I've
always thought a katana would be a real
good weapon but this is the apocalypse
it doesn't run out of ammo very sharp in
very short distance what do you guys
think awesome
I've got myself what what's your
favorite weapon um in real life or in
the game my real life like in real life
for this one be apocalypse that
hopefully where happened my favorite
weapon that we showed off in the in the
demo last year was it's what we call it
the lollipop internally so you take a
saw blade and you craft it onto a
baseball bat oh yeah and then it's a
some kind of oh it's kind of a one hit
kill spread through things like butter I
mean like a knife through butter it's
great yes yes that yeah that sounds like
distance as well that's great see one
wavelength yeah do you think about this
stuff I mean is it things you think of
you already said it's kind of like what
would you do in this um be epochal if
you have these conversations and then
that went into the game yeah in a lot of
ways and it's something where you know
there's people ask why you know why
zombie stuff why this post-apocalyptic
why is it so big and it's because my
theory is that you know we use
entertainment force for fantasy
wish-fulfillment escapism but who
escapes
who wants to escape to a world where
your family's gone where they're dead
and everything's out trying to kill you
like that doesn't sound like a quiet be
it's not very romantic or sexy but I
think that what what why we like it is
because it's a it's a test it's
something where it you know because we
will thankful the first thing I would do
is I'd like it's a the roof of this
building and I would like barricade all
the doors and I'd kill everybody take
our weapons and only let the the nice
people in or whatever
whatever we're running through ahead
were idiots for thinking that would
actually work but we all think I have a
game plan that would work so that feeds
into the kind of what would i do feeds
into everything we're doing and we're
actually calling this game kind of a
brutal test of survival you know test
your choices because we're really not
scripting a lot of our encounters we're
scripting victory conditions not methods
for getting their episode just because
it's a story and it's liberating because
we say here's your tools you know and
you know you can use any of them we're
not prescribing specifics in most cases
and the players are free to do what they
want in this greater a brutal test to
survival play it your way
yeah and story wise I think it's the
reason why like The Walking Dead is so
popular is because the best the best
stories are all about conflict and drama
and how you can't get more conflict than
hey if I step outside everything wants
to kill ya so just on a sort of primal
level just that you know like Jeff said
that it's not just the test though it's
the it's the just the everybody wants to
live yeah oh that's almost universal
everybody will fight for their last
breath right and so if you threaten that
and that becomes like on on the
hierarchy of needs just the you know the
ability to breathe and leave it and live
and eat that's that's that's pretty
basic yeah do that yeah and like you
said earlier the the greatest threat of
all is other people other people and I
think that's totally true yes I mean
that's a big thing in the Walking Dead -
it's like I go absolutely the encampment
sequence we saw during the conference
reminded me a lot of like going into you
know to find the governor or something
like that like just kind of taking over
what somebody else has already
established is that or how is the
balance between like fighting the
freaker's and fighting like actual
uninfected people
I think the boat if you take all of our
demos together that gives you a pretty
good idea yeah so I don't know that
we've ever actually sat down and figured
out the exact ratio of how many
freaker's versus how many Marauders it's
pretty well balanced I'm using a
balanced yeah because we're very
different right and that's not really
looking for is making sure the
experience never gets boring never gets
repetitive you know and so we use these
these ingredients to mix that up as much
as we can
yeah I mean sure you've heard this
question a million times so excuse me
but what is it like you know entering
the market at a time
there are quite a few games that are
featuring the undead at the moment like
how do you see days gone like fitting in
that realm we never really worried about
it to be honest
no because when we pitched it we were
you know again we're we're I'm great I'm
a great believer in using whatever
tropes to help you tell your story yeah
and it's just funny than in games we get
asked this but you know nobody else is
ever going to get asked that in any
other action movies right oh yeah like
yeah it's summer it's like well the
Schwarzenegger movie uses yours I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna see that movie you
know it's like oh my god yeah at Austin
so it's about can we do something
original with it yeah and I believe
where we are I mean the thing is is it
everything we're describing today is
it's it's as realistic as a game can be
and still be have a story and be an
action centric game but we really kind
of use that that tone is a guard against
zany ideas and crazy things so what we
new up we really cautious a guard that
even even internally for features and I
did want to do but also I think that we
just we don't think about those other
things we have an original idea that you
know that's made of things that games
are made of so that's that's what you
respond yeah but at the same time we
also have the Horde know yeah well the
game has that so we didn't try I said
after that feature was the right thing
to do but it's it's over a thousand
enemies moving at the player in real
yeah
fast we saw it last year I killed a
thousand of them yeah yeah no big deal
but it's a real thing I'm it's a tidal
wave that keeps coming at you and you
know we see we've seen games with lots
of zombies out there but and none where
they're that many moving at the player
absolute constant Lee and the player
must stay ahead of it and it's so you
know we didn't set out to make that or
distinguish your future but if you cast
your you answer your question it's like
we've got our realism our tone over the
relatability and then we have this
really killer feature where you know
there's over a thousand guys just coming
at you non-stop and it's terrifying
and you don't think we have is just
triple-a production values yeah it's one
of the reasons why it's taking so long
at this game it's like because we
started out we wanted to make you know
console game but we you know we didn't
want to sacrifice the way the characters
looked or the way the world looked just
because we were building such a big
world
and you know world it's filled with so
many freaker's and I think that's you
know it's hopefully you can see that in
the cinematics that we've shown that
they really kind of help draw the player
in so that when you're when you're
playing the world I think you kind of
forget at least I hope you will you'll
forget that hey this is you know this is
a game set in a post-apocalyptic world
all right yeah you know because yeah
lots of lots of fiction not just games
I've said in that absolutely right but
but I hope but I hope ours will draw you
in well it certainly seems to be doing
that already and all other people are
excited about it and you know what even
if people are asking the question oh
another zombie game I think there's a
very big awareness as you've said it's a
very unique take that you've got and it
seems like the concepts and themes that
you want to talk about sort of transcend
that sort of simple like genre like
there's a lot more going on beyond that
level um I love to ask when are we going
to be able to see more I know you guys
have the game coming out late December
this year um John will do that it's not
coming out December this year we're not
talking about release date oh okay all
right what's it like I can tell you that
what is inaccurate
okay those note lied to me and this is
terrible all right um content often does
that anyway uh you know what it must
have been one of those placeholder dates
that was like oh we don't know it's
coming out this year have you announced
any kind of idea twenty seventeen or
eighteen or it's just again we've been
really lucky because Sony's just gonna
give us the time to finish the game and
just do the best job we possibly can so
that's you know we're grateful that
we're not talking about release date
right now yeah have a lot of work to do
right yeah it's gonna be awesome
but I can't wait to play it so don't
wait to play it too and uh before you go
I would love to ask you about the tech I
know you've got what you call internally
hard tech for that how is how is that
been managing that and building that as
a process just a talented team of
engineers yeah yeah seriously it's like
you know because we're reusing the
Unreal 4 engine and we have engineers
that have that are that are you know
building on that and they had you know
the physics to get that many enemies on
the screen at once is a huge task not
just for engineering but for design to
figure out how do we how do we make a
game out of that I mean honestly that
was the bigger challenge and for the
character was ya the character team and
the animation team in the audio team I
mean is every
buddy but really the real challenge is
how do you turn that into a game how do
you make it fun to play yeah and and
it's been a it has been a challenge
we've been really fortunate with our
with our talent I mean that's something
where we it just lose it was never in
doubt that it could happen so yeah I
wish we could say there was a secret
formula to our process but it's just
some great people yeah
well that's fantastic thank you so much
for coming to talk to us we can't wait
to see more about the game yeah Jeff and
John thank you so much thank you you
made a very interesting looking game and
you know whenever we do get it which is
not at the end of this year I'm looking
forward to hearing more so thank you so
much for joining us do you stick with us
next up we've got ninokuni to